mais c'est peut-être pour bientôt
toujours à propos de sport l'immense
succès de la coupe d'afrique des nations
foule en liesse audiences records
qualité du jeu et c'est aussi une fête
pour le ghana qui organise l'événement
et où le football est une raison de
vivre et parfois un chemin vers
l'éducation manuel tissier vincent
bouffartigue dans les rues d'accra où
sur un terrain de fortune il y a
toujours un ballon qui roule
ces jeunes ghanéens ont une dizaine
d'années ils n'ont pas tous de
chaussures mais ce midi en pleine
chaleur il jouait avec un ballon de cuir
et des tenues fluo à deux pas de l'océan
ce gamin des rues vont disputer la
deuxième mi temps sur les bancs d'une
école la stricte academy d'accra un
établissement privé qui tente de donner
le goût de la lecture et de l'écriture à
des jeunes qui n'ont jamais connu
l'école ici le ballon est un appât nous
utilisons le foot comme un outil une
activité pour les amener ici leur donner
envie
lanciault le foot est un partenaire de
l'éducation est depuis quinze jours la
passion du ballon rond est encore montée
d'un cran au ghana le pays ne jure plus
que par ses black stars les étoiles
noires dirigée par le français claude
leroy héros national qui personne n'en
doute doit mener le pays à la victoire
que vous veniez le ghana va vous battre
j'aime le ghana est ce que tu as est bon
pour nous d'être en demi finale c'est
pour ça que nous sommes très heureux
demain soir pendant une heure et demie
ou un peu plus les rues d'accra seront
totalement déserte tout le monde sera
devant sa télévision ou au stade pour
voir si les black stars restent dans la
course et peuvent toujours prétendre
remporter une cinquième coupe d'afrique
des nations vingt-six ans après leur
dernier trophée